[Music]
on this Thursday night escalation and
retaliation Israel's military buildup
has advised to crush and Destroy Hamas
and
Gaza the fears for Canadians still
missing as more details emerge of the
atrocities committed by Hamas this is
something that can't even imagine in
like any dreams he cannot imagine that
no way out I speak with a Canadian
mother trapped in Gaza with her children
there's no vocabulary to exactly uh
describe what we are going through while
the first Canadians fleeing Israel get
out American Ally the message from the
US Secretary of State and the fate of
dozens of hostages held by
Hamas plus
jackpot the Millions for a Montreal man
after one lucky
Thanksgiving
global national with Donna freezen good
evening and thanks for joining us
Israel's prime minister is continuing
his tough rhetoric tonight comparing
Hamas to the so-called Islamic State
just as Isis was crushed so too will
Hamas be
crushed Israel launching a sixth day of
punishing air strikes on Gaza home to
more than 2 million Palestinians more
than 1,400 people there including
children have been killed Benjamin
netanyahu's office also posted graphic
photos two graphic to be aired on
television that it says show the bodies
of Israeli babies who were murdered and
burned in Saturday's brutal attack by
Hamas in southern Israel more than 12200
people died in that attack 130 Canadians
left Tel Aviv in an emergency airlift
today two other planes are set to depart
tomorrow though Canadians stuck in Gaza
can cannot get
out near the Gaza border the buildup of
Israeli military continues today Israel
said no electrical switch will be turned
on no water hydrant will be opened and
no fuel truck will enter until the
hostages Hamas is holding in Gaza are
freed our coverage begins with Jeff
simple in Jerusalem and a warning some
of the details in his story tonight are
difficult to listen to
Jeff Donna tonight we're learning new
details about those hostages and about
the atrocities carried out by Hamas they
call themselves zaka 1500 Israeli
volunteers who conduct search rescue and
Recovery operations to ensure the
victims receive a proper burial Yosi
landow founded the organization 33 years
ago originally from New York he's
responded to disasters all over the
world including 9/11 but nothing
prepared him for this have you ever seen
anything like what you've seen here no
no
never never in Just 4 days his team has
recovered
670 bodies including more than 100 here
in this small community near the Gaza
border with a population of 1200 until
Saturday when Hamas gunman entered the
community and started murdering
civilians including the most horrific
atrocities landow has ever seen
I wouldn't call them animals because
it's a shame for the animals Lando says
he found a pregnant mother and even
babies who'd been stabbed and shot or
you see a mother that is hugging a baby
and there's only one
shot going through the baby and the
mother this is something
that can't even imagine Lando's team
also saw Trails of blood heading towards
the Gaza border injured Hamas gunmen
perhaps or their hostages the only thing
that I care about is that my loved on
will come home safely 11 members of
Annalie milstein's family are now
presumed hostages of Hamas including
three children their extended family
gathering was interrupted by the sound
of gunfire they sent anxious text
messages to analie's family in Tel Aviv
what was the last message you received
from them we're in big trouble we hope
we will survive this and we love you she
says they tried calling over and over
until finally someone answered his phone
with a bad Hebrew with an Arab accent
and uh he said to the friend that he is
kidnapped Hamas claims to be holding
more than 100 Israeli hostages and
Global News has learned of another
Canadian on that
list this video was recorded inside of a
safe house after Hamas gunman attacked
partygoers at a music festival that's
22-year-old Israeli Canadian sheer
Georgie her last known sighting our only
hope is that she's kidnapped her family
says they've checked everywhere
including the morg but no sign of her
the videos we've seen from the the
people they kidnapped and raped and
abuse these people I don't know if it's
better to be dead or to found kidnapped
it's it's horrible it's horrible and I
can't believe that the world is actually
letting something like this happened in
2023 Hamas warned earlier this week it
would execute one hostage every time
Israel strikes a home in Gaza so far as
we know Donna the group has not made
good on that threat all right Jeff
simple in Jerusalem thanks as Israelis
mourn and bury their dead people in Gaza
wait for the next Israeli bomb to drop
Israel has put the more than 2 million
Palestinians there under siege cutting
off water power food and
Medicine Israeli forces have been
instructing Palestinians to assemble in
four densely populated parts of the Gaza
Strip but inside these zones civilians
are not out of danger in Gaza City
entire neighborhoods have been leveled
at least seven mosques have been
destroyed Israel says it has already
dropped over 6,000 bombs on Gaza since
Saturday damage extends from the North
to the South where several residential
Towers have been
destroyed Israel says it is targeting
Hamas Fighters and Hamas has a history
of using civilians as human Shields
according to gaza's health Ministry have
the more than 1,400 people killed more
than 60% are women and
children at the morg at chifa hospital
bodies are coming in faster than
relatives can claim them the UN warns
the humanitarian situation is growing
more desperate by the
[Music]
hour Canada's Foreign Affairs Department
says about 70 Canadians are stuck in the
Gaza Strip right now they're going to
bomb all these buildings Asia Mur is
among them she moved to Gaza in 2014
she's there with her husband and two
young children along with her parents
and other relatives they had been taking
cover in her parents basement but fled
after the house was D damaged by Israeli
air strikes and they've since relocated
a number of times trying to escape the
explosions AIA thank you for speaking
with us I know you have your 2-year-old
daughter there with you on your lap how
are you and your family doing right
now um we are not doing well actually um
it's unimaginable and uh there's no
vocabulary to exactly uh describe what
we are going through do you have a place
to sleep do you have food do you have
water uh we we've we've evacuated uh
five times already since we uh since the
um escalation started and um uh we've
been feeling so petrified and in so much
her Terror because uh there's no place
uh safe uh
um not sure if you could hear the
background but um I
can what are we
hearing uh there's just some
bombs is it going on all the
time yes you could say that
yes um we had to evacuate five times uh
again like I said there's no place
that's safe uh we've went to a a
security clearance uh Place uh and we
had to evacuate twice uh the first time
was uh they they got a call from a prank
a settler prank um that they were going
to that we had to flee the um the
location uh we went to a family resident
uh like a relative and the next morning
when we got clear to go back to uh the
the hotel
um um we got
uh as soon as we get there um uh the
without without any previous warning uh
a a bomb just dropped on a bomb the a
bomb hit dropped on a building right
across from the hotel and immediately
after uh phosphorus uh uh bombs were
dropped and we started choking uh we had
to take cover for safety we had to cover
our nose uh uh
both most of our lungs actually are we
are suffering from from the aftermath of
inhaling so much of the phph force uh
smoke and also again we had to leave the
hotel and again we went back to the
relative uh um house uh for now it seems
for now it's seems It's the safest
location I don't want to say safest uh
because any minute right now
uh we can get a call telling us to uh to
evacuate the area and the whole the
whole neighborhood and I I want to say
about speaking of neighborhoods what's
been happening to Gaza Strip is a mass
extermination to neighborhoods and to
families um
um it's it's it's a horrific catastrophe
actually what been going on are the
Israelis giving some warnings before
they launch air
strikes not always uh um not
always sometimes they are and most of
the time they are they
aren't you know Israel says that it's
targeting Hamas Fighters there that
every Hamas fighter is a dead man they
say we know of course that women and
children are dying there too and
innocent civilians what do you want the
world to know about that
mm- uh the targets are are are to
civilians uh you go to the hospital and
uh it's it's packed it's packed with uh
uh children women uh injured uh uh
murdered uh uh kids and and and families
I mean like there's if you if you follow
the news uh which doesn't uh reach uh to
Canada uh I family of 18 25 are
completely completely wiped
off um we we the the actual hospital um
announced that they are running out of
fuel uh to for the generators uh the uh
the the injured they actually seeing the
the patients on the ground and the uh um
there's no there's no space in the in
the there's in the mortgage there's
there isn't at all
um AA you have a two-year-old and a
four-year-old how are they doing fivey
old a five-year-old uh well my son yeah
my son was uh very um he he's really
scared to be honest and he doesn't
understand what's going on he keeps
asking questions why um and he sees that
we are in ter he sees that we are so uh
scared and um you know I tried to tell
him you know you're strong we can be all
strong together he told me I cannot
handle it I cannot I cannot handle this
I cannot go through it um and uh he
tells me I want to leave I need to I I I
don't want to stay here I don't want to
stay in this in in this war zone um
um uh my 2-year-old daughter every time
uh she's she she sleeps literally in in
in my lap and um every time a bomb goes
off she has to to she grabs on to me
while she's sleeping she goes like this
and um
um um she she'd say like when she hears
it she'd say like uh a rocket or a
bomb uh I'm scared she sees she says a
word the words I'm scared also uh what I
can do for them to be honest tell them
it's okay we're okay I'm here I'm with
you um honestly we're just waiting to be
saved and uh to be seen by the Canadian
government to to uh to to to help us um
there is there is some talk uh there is
some talk Asia about opening up a safe
Corridor to get people like you and your
family out have you heard anything about
that have you had any contact with the
Canadian
government I only had the contact where
they told me once they have more
information they will contact us uh no
uh idea of uh anything and to be honest
uh the the the we're in an SOS situation
I mean like uh we are evacuating uh
there's no internet and there's there's
no Wi-Fi at all like in in in in while
we're evacuating you know while walking
in the streets or going from one
location to another um so or or
landlines for me to call them and tell
them hey we're here you know so they're
expecting us from here in our situation
to email them and register and then uh
weit wait for an email and then after uh
just
today um a news anchor told me that he's
heard that we have to contact the the
ramala conso and I was like what like
nobody told me that I have to to contact
them no one gave me that information
that I have to go and call the the
Consul in RA in ramala and also yester
uh today in the morning uh I did I'm not
sure if you hear
it um
today in the morning uh on a radio
station um in Canada also uh I heard for
the first time that they were saying
that it might take days for for them to
take us out but hello like what are you
what am I expected to do from from today
till two three or seven or five days I
don't know how long what's the plan for
us I mean what's the safety uh location
are they providing for us Canadians
right now on the ground um to to to to
be secure you know what I mean uh
nothing nothing at all it sounds like do
you feel like you've been
abandoned yes definitely I I do feel
like that because
um I I mean like for for for me to be
heard to be honest um my family uh back
home in Canada and my friends oh my God
my friends they kept Conta me they they
cont so many contacts whatever contact
they got to to get the media to contact
me to to get me in touch with with uh
with with Canadian um uh sources just
like you and uh like uh many other uh
news um anchors just to be heard and to
for people to see us civilians here AA
it sounds like you're living minute by
minute right now
we are actually we are living minute by
minute because uh like I said um given
what I've been through honestly like I
thought evacuating from my house going
through the first night underground the
basement um in the sauna room uh and and
seeing the the what I saw that morning
and and and having to evacuate I was
like okay no no no we need to get out
right and this is what I told my son I
will get you out as we were walking on
rubbles trying to to seek uh a a secure
area where we can uh stop a car to go to
another saf it was a disaster honestly
it was it was so horrifying and seeing
my kids go through it
all it's undescribable to be honest and
then the next day when we got to again
I'm going to say again to a security
clearance
hotel we we we got we got a call to
evacuate I mean okay yeah it's it's
impossible to find a safe
place AIA we will check in with you
again thank you for taking time with
us thank you thank you so
much the Canadian government said today
assisted departures from Gaza are not
possible at this time but they are
working with the UN and other
International organizations to try to
find Solutions and prime minister Justin
Trudeau says members of the standing
rapid development team will be deployed
to the region that's a group gr of
specialized officials that were told
will work with Canada's embassies and
consulates to help Canadians in
distress the Safety and Security of
Canadians at home and abroad is always
our top priority the situation on the
ground is
volatile Canadians in Israel are turning
up at the airport in Tel Aviv as the
first evacuation flights organized by
the Canadian government leave there our
Crystal ganing spoke to some of them a
bright red Beacon a helpful sight for
exhausted and desperate Canadians
looking to escape I've done everything
to stay here through other Wars and
other situations and never thought in my
mind to
leave but when you start realizing that
this war could become
Global um that's a big fear Shirley
Simon says her husband is staying behind
leaving and taking the kids to safety
she says feels like she's cheating the
kidss she says won't sleep alone they're
terrified and she's also struggling you
try to be brave and fake it more than
1,600 people have registered with the
federal government looking for flights
out the government says it will run two
flights daily to Athens then people will
be given a special code to book an Air
Canada flight to Toronto this is
different Butterfield says after what he
witnessed he just wants to get home to
Vancouver and hug his daughter he's not
sure when or if he'll get on a flight
but he's willing to sit it out that
coffee place is open all night so lots
of coffee they've opened up the gate for
us on the third floor or checking
counter another group heads
off tired but grateful all the flights
are booked Muriel Wolfman however is
still waiting her dad David is booked on
a commercial flight Monday home to
Montreal his last one was cancelled he
is health issues and he did bring extra
medication but that runs out in a few
days the family also registered him for
an evacuation flight I'm stressed
because I'm trying to balance everyone's
emotions right so it's okay we're going
to be
okay I have no right to be like this cuz
people are suffering a lot more than
us fearing for their safety and unsure
what will happen next after the attacks
on Saturday wolfman's sister cousin and
their children all moved into her home
David face times with his wife and
daughters back in Canada my wife she's
an
Israeli and she was here in 1973 on Kore
war and she knows what it is you know
the family says it's not just about air
strikes coming from Gaza but the fear of
more militants hiding in Israel
preparing for another strike there
haven't been widespread attacks on the
streets of Israel since last weekend but
late Thursday two police officers were
shot and wounded by an attacker in
Jerusalem's Old City the as salent was
shot dead the popular front for the
liberation of Palestine claimed
responsibility Crystal Gan in Global
News
Jerusalem what's going on in Israel and
Gaza has inflamed tensions and some
members of Canada's Muslim and Jewish
communities are feeling anxious police
say there are no credible threats but
officers are stepping up Patrol at
religious sites to ensure the anger in
Israel and Gaza doesn't spill over here
McKenzie gray
reports an increased police presence
near some of Toronto's most prominent
Jewish institutions ahead of a day of
global demonstrations called on by the
former leader of Hamas putting the
community on edge there's no specific
threat to the city of Toronto however
our communities have spoken clearly that
they don't feel safe and we are being
responsive to that concern a similar
sentiment shared in Ottawa with police
saying there have been no reported hate
motivated incidents targeting either a
Palestinian Muslim or a Jewish Community
member we must always stand United as
Canadians this is something that is core
to Canada we take care of each other
despite the political and police
reassurances some Jewish Canadians are
taking extra precautions Global News has
agreed to not identify this mother who's
pulling her six and nine-year-olds out
of school tomorrow I've had very scary
thoughts dropping my kids off at school
this week felt different than it did in
the past the principle of ottawa's
largest Jewish school seeing some
families follow suit most parents are
choosing to continue to send their kids
to school of course every now and again
a parent is holding a different kind of
anxiety and we understand that John
mitzer crediting the resilience of his
students and staff these are teachers
who show up every day with broken hearts
and whose job it is is to show up and be
present and emotionally available for
children who desperately need them
similar on ease being felt by
Palestinian Canadians as the National
Council of Canadian Muslims is set to
hold an emergency meeting tonight on
islamophobia from the perspective of our
community uh there is a little bit of
unrest a lot bit of uh people who are
feeling anxious the RCMP say they're
aware of threats against the Jewish
community on social media and are
calling on Canadians to use increased
vigilance Donna McKenzie thanks the US
Secretary of State in Israel coming up
what he said and how the us could help
free hostages taken by
Hamas The American Secretary of State
heard firsthand about the horror of the
Hamas attack last weekend Anthony
blinkin arrived in telie and he met
survivors of the attack on that music
festival they urged him to make a
priority of finding those who were
kidnapped there are a lot of friends
that are kept captive now in
Gaza
and we were saved by Miracle but there
are friends that we love
that Lincoln told her he would do
everything possible to try to bring the
hostages home Joel senic
reports see sorry it's under these
circumstances America's top Diplomat now
on the ground ground in the Middle East
thank you for your important visit here
today US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin meeting with top Israeli
officials and describing photographic
evidence he was showing of Israeli
civilians who were brutally killed in
hamas's attack it's
simply depravity in the worst imaginable
way us officials say at least 27 US
citizens were killed in the attack and
14 others remain unaccounted Ed for some
of which are believed to be among the
dozens being held captive in Gaza we're
doing everything we can to secure the
release of the hostages working closely
with our Israeli Partners the FBI's
hostage and rescue team is highly
specialized hostage negotiation experts
say the US will add some of the most
experienced professionals to the rescue
effort you can collaborate and
brainstorm and come up with other ideas
secretary blinkin also discussing the
humanitarian toll drawing a clear
distinction
we know Hamas didn't commit its heinous
acts with the interests of Palestinian
people in mind us officials say they are
raising the issue of a humanitarian
Corridor with Israel and Egypt which
borders Gaza these two countries Israel
and Egypt are both the among the biggest
recipients of us Aid so that kind of
gives the United States some clout here
influence this former State Department
officials says should be used as the
conflict will impact the region for
years to come part of the American role
as a close Ally and friend of Israel is
to remind them of that as well that
there will be a day after and so keep
that in mind as you're moving forward in
your operations secretary blinken's trip
continues with stops in a number of
countries over the coming days he says
his mission is clear to stop the
conflict from spreading and secure the
release of hostages held by Hamas Joel
senic Global News
Washington still ahead the devastating
impact of an earthquake in
[Music]
Afghanistan the man accused of
intentionally killing four members of a
Muslim family in London Ontario
testified in court today 22-year-old
Nathaniel veltman took the stand in his
own defense he spoke of his rigid
Christian fundamentalist upbringing and
his difficult relationship with his
mother who did he described as a
religious fanatic who kept him out of
school belman testified he left home at
16 saying hated being around his mother
he's accused of deliberately hitting
five members of the offal family with
his truck while they were out for a walk
in London onario on June 6th of
2021 there's troubling news out of
Afghanistan the UN says more than 90% of
the people who were killed in last
week's earthquake were women and
children Taliban officials say more than
2,000 people died in the 6.3 magnitude
quake in Western Afghanistan on Saturday
the UNICEF field office in the area says
women and children work more likely home
when the disaster struck the earthquake
and many aftershocks flattened entire
Villages destroying hundreds of mud
brick homes and
buildings next the Montreal man who's
giving thanks for his Thanksgiving
grocery
[Music]
run a montre old man had lots to
celebrate this past Thanksgiving weekend
thanks to something he picked up while
grocery
[Applause]
shopping Pierre re bought a Lotto Max
ticket at a Montreal Supermarket last
week while picking up things for
Thanksgiving dinner with his daughter a
turned out to be the $50 million winning
Pick he says he'll keep his job in
shipping for a while and plans to use
the winnings to buy a new house a car
and go on a family
vacation what he won is a pittance
compared to California jackpot someone
there won an astounding $1
1.73 billion the winning ticket holder
hasn't been revealed yet the ticket was
sold at a small convenience store North
of Los Angeles and it's not even the
biggest prize in US Lotto history that
was A2 billion jackpot someone won last
year